there were a lot of reasons why I joined
the Navy a lot of them practical so i
looked at the navy as an opportunity to
have some adventures while doing
something that actually mattered and
would contribute to my future i put in
for a program called the steam into
Admiral for the 21st century or stay 21
and it's a program for enlisted sailors
to get an officer's Commission and after
being accepted to that I was like well
you know I'm already doing so well so I
applied to columbia the first reason i
was looking at columbia was because I'd
seen in the news about how big of a deal
it was that they were bringing the ROTC
back and I just seemed like a really
amazing opportunity to be able to use my
program to go to a school like Columbia
and that it was the first time that had
been offered was just amazing so I felt
like it's an opportunity that i really
had to take advantage of in addition to
that Columbia has the school general
studies and with my background being
what it was the school general studies
just seemed like a really great home for
someone who didn't have a traditional
education who had taken some time off
who had spent some time in the military
my primary goal at Columbia was
definitely to finish my math degree I
always wanted to study math so it's a
really big accomplishment to finally
finish that and I really do hope that I
can keep studying math even if i don't
go on to grad school to study it in
particular it's always been my first
love but then everything else that I've
learned at Columbia all the other
different things the core requirements
you know the art home music come
philosophy those are things that I was
never exposed to when i was younger
prior to my coming to columbia i was
actually a petty officer 2nd class i was
actually part of an iraqi language pilot
program so we were the first ones to go
through the program which was an
interesting experience but was really
great because we got to learn the
dialect as opposed to the modern
Standard Arabic which is actually isn't
used colloquially so when I went to
Jordan the summer for example i was able
to talk with the locals really
comfortably it was a science class
science credits and we traveled all
around Jordan Amman and acaba saw the
Dead Sea it was a really amazing trip
and it was four weeks and it was the
added bonus of me being able to use my
language the day after graduation I'll
be getting my commission into the US
Navy so that'll be on campus at low
library and from that point on I'll be
an instant in the US Navy and after that
I'm selected to go to pilot school down
in Pensacola